[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
on commence avec la levé de l'alerte
neige Vergl dans les ivelines oui
maintenu jusqu'à ce midi l'alerte orange
neige Vergl a bien été levée dans les
ivelines aujourd'hui le département
passe ainsi en vigilance jaune si la
situation s'améliore la prudence reste
deise attention notamment au risque de
chute sur les sols encore verre glacés
par endroit prudence également sur les
routes et à Mantel jolie les professeurs
du lycée Jean Rostan sont en grève oui
depuis lundi tous les enseignants du
lycée se sont mis en grève ils dénoncent
leurs conditions de travail et
l'insécurité qui s'installe depuis
septembre dernier fait en date au mois
de décembre où une enseignante
d'histoire géographie de l'établissement
a été placée sous protection par
l'académie de Versailles cette dernière
avait reçu des menaces de mort et son
domicile avait été recouvert de tag
depuis le début de l'année scolaire de
nombreux incidents s'était déjà produit
dans l'établissement comme des jets de
pierre des départs d'incendie ou encore
des menaces envers le personnel et ce
n'est pas un cas isolé dans les ivelines
en octobre à rambouillé une enseignante
du lycée Bascan avait également reçu des
menaces de mort hier soir avait lieu les
vœux du président du département des
Yvelines que faut-il retenir Gabriel
tout à fait Mathilde et cette année
encore les vœux se sont faits conjo
conjointement entre le département des
Yvelines et celui des haut de scènees la
cérémonie avait lieu au Hara de jardi à
Marne lacoquette alors parmi les
personnalités présentes de nombreux élus
mais aussi des chefs d'entreprise et des
sportifs durant son discours Pierre
Bédier est notamment revenu sur la
situation financière du département je
vous propose qu'on l'écoute le
département est dans une situation
financière extrêmement difficile parce
que nous avons d'un côté un seul impôt
donc nous ne définissons même plus le
taux hein qui nous a été laissé par
l'État comme un pourmois
cet impôt a un rendement bien moindre
puisqu'il repose sur l'immobilier qui
est en crise chacun le sait et nous
avons une explosion des dépenses sociale
puisque la la société française ne va
pas bien et l'économie ne va pas aussi
bien qu'on voudrait nous le dire alors
malgré la volonté du département
d'impacter au minimum les ivelinois les
défis vont être nombreux pour l'année
2024 je pense que 2024 va être une année
de combat ça va être une année de combat
combat pour les sportifs pour gagner
leur médaill et puis nous combat élus
les élus locaux en particulier pour
faire comprendre à ceux qui nous
gouvernent qu'il ne peut pas y avoir de
démocratie dynamique et de démocratie
qui qui représente exactement les
aspirations des Français sans
décentralisation sans s'appuyer sur les
collectivités locales que sont les
communes et les
départements on poursuit ces
informations du jour avec l'attentat du
SuperU de treb 6 ans après ce l'attentat
qui avait coûté la vie à Arnaud Beltram
6 ans après la femme sauvé par le
gendarme sort du silence avec un livre
intitulé sa vie pour la mienne oui dans
ce livre par paru aux éditions
ège l'ancienne caissière du SuperU rend
hommage à l'ancien officier des Yvelines
qui lui a SAU sauvé la vie le jour de
l'attentat un livre à la mémoire d'un
homme d'exception comme elle le qualifie
pour rappel Arnaud Beltram avait passé
une partie de sa carrière dans les
ivines notamment au sein du groupement
blindé de gendarmerie mobile de versaill
satori aujourd'hui d'ailleurs mathildeun
rue porte le nom du colonel dans le
quartier des chantiers et on termine ces
informations Gabriel avec du sport et
plus particulièrement du volet avec une
défaite en Coupe de France pour l'Union
Sportive de conflan André Zoui oui hier
soir le club du CJ volleyball qui évolu
en élite affronté à domicile l'équipe de
Ligue B Saint-Quentin volet pour le 3è
tour masculin de Coupe de France les
ivelinois se sont inclinés 3 à0 face au
Picard malgré tout l'équipe a fait une
belle compétition elle avait notamment
remporté ses deux derniers matchs face à
Cann et à jacio et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag setweet news